healthy snacks to keep a whole family
energized on your next road trip so
there's no arguments in the backseat or
with your husband please welcome
dietician Abby sharp nice to have you so
I just give us a road trip with my son
and I always have snacks you never know
when it hits yeah exactly yeah prepared
be prepared that's what this is all
about the thing when you pack your
suitcase
you gotta pack snacks right so we got
snacks for the car we do so for me my
go-to always almonds because honest they
don't require refrigeration right
they're not gonna make a big fat mess if
someone goes over a road bump in yeah
they're not spilling everywhere they're
not gonna ruin me upholstery you know
what the great deal is yeah is that
later on maybe three months later it's a
treasure oh do you know I'm saying
you're going yeah yeah that's okay a
french fry not so much no but in almonds
okay that's right and they have this
amazing combination of fiber and protein
and healthy fats and complex carbs that
keeps someone feeling full longer right
so that you don't need to pull over and
grab chips in like an hour right that's
exactly right
yeah and look at these cute little one
ounce tins is this not cute every kid in
the car gets their own snack no fighting
right like what you said no fighting in
the car right right and if you have like
a toddler that's not really snacking out
and have a tantrum
please points to it you can have a
little dance party in the car why not
yes so these the my job yeah so what
else do we have here well if you have a
cooler and you have space I like to do
some low-fat cheese and some whole-grain
crackers pack those in right um I do
carrots with hummus of course and a
little container right apple slices I
slice them up spritz some of the lemon
juice they don't go Brown right little
cinnamon it's like apple pie without all
the sugar and calories about the
cinnamon that would be good and you
eliminate that problem of having the
core to have to hold right or in the car
right and ever Leah's mom that's your
job yes and lots of water bottles
yeah I'm gonna stay hydrated and there
you go there you go that's that's why
you prepare it but let's just say you
run out of food after the first hour
yeah
it happens these long run transit was so
good so bad
so now what do you do well coffee shop
is first cuz mom and dad you're gonna
need your fit I'm like sure you gotta go
look coffee shops so a lot of a lot of
things times I see parents telling their
kids you know you can't have the
doughnut or the cookie because we know
those are not the best breakfast options
nutritious but they go for the low-fat
or the bran muffin instead thinking
that's a healthier choice right right
you think so you think so but a lot of
these healthy muffins have extra sugar
added to them because they have to make
up for the lack of fat or you know or
the out of the extra fiber right so yeah
your muffin has twice the calories and
fat and sugar than have you just given
them the doughnut in the first place I
see right what's the option there well
you know a lot of these coffee shops now
have low fat yogurt and berries you can
do a whole grain oatmeal which has some
5r in it and I all say if the case are
really begging you for a treat just go
for a little mini biscotti which are
naturally low in sugar and fat or on one
or two of the mini doughnuts portion
control yeah well you know if they're
begging yeah it's better than one bag
I'm betting yeah whatever that sounds
good that sounds fishy control so that
is do it how you know that it's nothing
it's deceiving for sure abyssal zone ow
we're gonna go to the gas station of a
tavini
yes cuz you gotta get gas and those gas
stations they earn notorious for those
monster sized soft drinks which can pack
as many as many calories and sugar as
for chocolate bars you're not gonna eat
four chocolate bars in one go so you're
probably not gonna want
not everyday right you're watching
though right okay so if you're looking
for a sugar-free option I like to do a
citrus flavored sparkling water gives
that same fizziness factor I need the
fizzy exactly but without all the
calories and sugar right now with snacks
at the gas station but you're getting
better
they aren't better exact can't believe
they serve now yeah so I often see
parents gravitate towards the the real
fruit snacks or the fruit snacks in the
candy aisle because they're often
marketed as being really healthy because
they stay right on package made with
real fruit right so you know the issue
is there's you know other than a little
bit of fruit juice that it says on the
ingredients it's a lot of sugar a lot of
corn syrup food dye right so for more
nutritious option head right to the the
refrigerator section because this is the
thing all on these gas stations now have
refrigerator section yes they do you can
get whole fruit or cut-up fruit to have
some fiber in it it's gonna help
everyone feel more weight yeah and it's
just sweet little treat us they also
have yogurt and cheese and hard-boiled
eggs are already available sizzling with
protein so you really want to hang out
at the refrigerator section in the gas
and then we've got one minute left to
talk about let's just say yeah if you're
still hungry if you're still hungry I
know on vacation I said to play said
when are we gonna stop T because we just
can't network up you go to a restaurant
yeah what do you order I tell you that
looks good but ya know three things to
think about when you're when you're not
being a nice menu just go first of all
crispy always seems batter deep-fried
and loaded with calories and fat crispy
that's crazy so you want to go for
something grilled with your chicken or
fish sure now
sandwich fillings chicken salad egg
salad tuna salad have a lot of mayo
added to them so your best bet if you're
looking for something lower fat is lean
meats
lots of veggies and go for mustard
instead of mail right I love that I love
that that's made and I also do this I
just pretend I just take that off yeah
you can always if you're looking for
lower carb yeah you can just
I feel better grab mine take it take you
know open it Oh
okay okay say last watch your side smart
because we know the French fries have a
lot of calories that salt but nowadays
you can swap them through no charge low
fat baked potatoes yeah sometimes the
apple slices for the kids meals just you
could do a broth based soup or a side
salad and you just want to be careful
with the side salad because some
packages of salad dressing can have as
many calories right it's a bacon
cheeseburger that's great that's right
can cheeseburger salad dressing yeah
let's go so yes for the light light or
your own lemon exactly she's hot the
packet okay okay way to go like on a
road trip with you all right
thanks to Abby everybody got to take a
break